thank you thank you everybody for your
patience
it really gives me
extraordinary pleasure to welcome you
all here tonight uh this is the first
real day of the
2022-2023 academic year at the yale
school of architecture
also gives me great pleasure to welcome
you to the yale university art gallery
which is yale's spectacular art museum
if you don't know it already
our lectures typically occur in hastings
hall in the basement of the school of
architecture's home paul rudolph hall
across the street
however given the interest in tonight's
speaker we needed a bigger space
and our colleagues at the art gallery
have generously shared their auditorium
with us
the pandemic rules in place here which
i'm happy to see you all observing is
that everyone must be masked and
capacity in the room is limited to 75
percent we do have an overflow room uh
at the school of architecture so there
nobody's missing this lecture
tonight's speaker
is the renowned architect francis curray
based in berlin francis is this
semester's louis icon visiting professor
in architecture
so it's even more suitable that we're in
this building the khan visiting
professorship endowment was established
in 1980 through a series of gifts from
architects in honor of the great louis
khan who taught architecture at yale
between 1947 and 1957.
you sit in a building designed by khan
which opened in 1953 and we are across
the street from another uh the yale
center for british art completed
posthumously in 1977.
former khan visiting professors include
frank gehry peter eisenman who is with
us tonight todd williams and billy chen
who are also with us tonight tom
pfeiffer francine hoban and lena gottmay
francis i cannot tell you how delighted
we are one that you have returned to
yale to your family here in new haven in
the united states
and that you are joining us this year at
the as the louis icon visiting professor
of architecture
i'm not going to bury the lead any
further as you all know francis curray
was the winner of the
2022 pritzker architecture prize
the 45th pritzker laureate he is also
the first person from africa to be so
honored
born in burkina faso kerry's practice
practices based in berlin
and in addition to the pritzker he has
received among many many other awards
the global wholesome award and the
arnold burner memorial prize in
architecture from the american academy
of arts and letters
he's an honorary fellow of the american
institute of architects the royal
institute of architects in canada and is
a chartered member of the royal
institute of british architects
his biography is better known thanks to
the attention his work has received
since being recognized by the pritzker
so i will not repeat it
i think we're all interested in hearing
from francis and probably not so much
from me
but let me just say that in addition to
being a profoundly gifted architect he
is an extraordinary and gracious human
being
in these times i believe where arrogance
often follows achievement and its
accompanying attention francis remains
curious and interested generous and
caring and continues through
architecture and buildings to contribute
to the betterment of the world
please join me in welcoming francis
curray
hello hello
i'm very happy that i have been told
many times that i'm with my family which
is good for me
i have to agree and confess that time
has become a very very very rare and
luxury luxury good in my life
so
i was hoping this
lecture to be wow
then i found myself running with
technology and then my office is already
shut down it is like six hours a time
difference
however deborah thank you so much
this lecture today i will show you a lot
of pictures my problem was because i
already spoke here because i don't want
to bother people i was trying to show
you the new things i'm working on
um while hoping to have them ivan was
traveling to shut take pictures of all
of this
project so i got them
but it was not easy to put them on my
computer so that's why it took me so
long
i will kill you with a lot of pictures
so um i don't care it's not
in a classroom
i want to say
that today is a memorable day for me
um
when i got an invitation i said wow
i will come and that which should be my
very first lecture in the u.s
saints covet
and coming back to yale is a great honor
not just simply because of the happiness
to be able to work again with martin
now coming back here
you know
let's be sincere as a prix laureate
you really feel that i'm still deep
under emotions
and
coming here
bring me choice
and
gratitude
because
allowed me to say without billy seen
my work would have never been even
discovered
it is because of billy that i was
awarded a can
award
a philosopher told me this lady
you know do you know this lady i know i
don't know this lady
showing to to
billy when i was standing with my father
in delhi
she fought for you like a lion
fighting for her babies
so
in the corridors at the school you will
heard martin and me fighting to say
billy is our mother
you have to sincerely take this under
account i was lucky and happy
that someone like her
was sitting in the jury didn't know me i
loved my work
um today i'm here with a lot of
gratitude billy
you know your son has won the place car
but i'm also full of gratitude
because you know it
i came here because deborah got me here
and my dream was to connect to have a
network you know to really also learn
from this school because i have a chair
teaching chair in munich where i'm
supposed to teach in english while i was
hoping to teach in german because this
is the language that i can in europe
additional to french so i came
full of
you know
hope to just meet
but now
to realize
that she would be part of the jury for
prisca and then that's that my work now
has been being awarded can you imagine
how much
i was struggling to really come on the
stage and really to
be normal and speak i'm not a normal guy
anymore
now
this is past
who who
knows me know that i will normally dance
i will stamp i will show you how
music in my culture become part of my
architecture how the women will work
hard and then to overcome the hard work
they will sing they will dance and they
will make a flow now
i'm considered to be serious i cannot do
this anymore
so so let me just start
okay
so to all our friends that have joined
us thank you i try to invite just a
couple
um
later i miss you you guys so i'm very
happy that you're here now i have no
fear anymore
so
this work has
yeah
this work just started
because
i grew up in a place
and there was nothing
there was no school that's why i had to
leave my parents very early
just to go abroad
and i'm a private person now even more
but at that time being a student in
germany i was already feeling i am
privileged so i wanted to give something
i don't like this word of giving back
you know it has become very heavy uh but
i just wanted to do something for my
people i wanted to create the school so
that the kids could stay home and be
able to attend education what brought me
to europe
and
we started
very naive very naive to really see what
is available
we have locally available materials you
have people that are full of enthusiasm
and looking to contribute and so with
that i just started to to get
and honestly
especially for the student that what you
see here was built when i was on your
position i was a little older i started
very late to study
many people don't know that
but i was academically on your age and
yes i was able to do that
and that's what billy has awarded uh
prisca
okay no no
the techniques may not work also because
i'm nervous
she said don't touch but i need your
help however
just where is uh
let me try again
no
so while she's coming to help and fix no
i'm
i just created this school um where
there was no other opportunities
and then my people were so uh excited
that we were able to do it it was not it
was new very modern but it was not like
coming from outside because that is how
architecture is being seen is not i
really need you to come and bring it
back
okay so and architecture has been seeing
because modern architecture that we're
talking being documented started
because with the colonial time they
built huge things but no one could
relate to those buildings and so what i
did was modern but for my people it was
something at their reach you know
because it was part of it
honestly this is the beginning of my
career
i just want to go back
and so
it didn't took me very long
that people start to ask for more of my
project and still i didn't consider it
to be
me myself to be architect i was
considering myself as actionist
and then you would be surprised to see
that i've been traveling a lot to do
lectures the truth aid here i was not
running to show
off or to show look at what i'm able to
do it was simply because i needed the
money
you know if
really honestly i i discovered myself
flowing to the u.s
for 200 2 000
and then the flight was of course paid
who will not come to the u.s yes yeah as
a student i didn't have that privilege
so i started to come
and i started to be everywhere fighting
with swollen eyes
but you know i was sharing what was
moving me to people and i was getting
paid
one more back
and i will be breath
good
yeah so
how do you build in that environment
uh what i do
what i do is a lot of mock-up real
one-to-one mock-up and to really test
because i couldn't afford to have a
professional joining us and so we built
mock-up and that is so
a picture that is into me because
i did it
running with the fiber
hoping the structure that you see will
not collapse
because you want to prove your people
that you know better you're coming from
a community no one has seen you building
you know because to gain knowledge
you're gonna run after your grandfather
or your father or your grandmother
for a long time and acquire knowledge
and then they should be beaten up and
when you come
you grow everyone will know you are
builder but francis disappeared from the
community he went to a country called
germany
and he's spending so much time instead
of coming back
we have nothing from him and he came
back and said hey guys i know how to
build
can you imagine that we believe you
in the u.s maybe
so
we had to do a lot of tests
i hope it's gonna go
i'm pressing that it's not going
yeah with hand
yeah so this is already the extension
of the school and from that moment i was
sure i was able to build
and then i couldn't stop
so i will be coming back to to the west
mainly in europe first
um just try to raise money
and
i will go in schools in germany talk to
kids
and convince them that africa is
beautiful it's so great
but it's missing opportunities you have
a lot of little kids your age having no
opportunities honestly this is how i
raise money
not serious institution would give you
money because they will say why it's you
going to build a school and not the
government
because they don't know that
infrastructure is not the same like in
the west you know
so
i built it and every time
so here when it came to color
the entire village was part of it so i
don't want to
go food about it is about
participation
really when i was doing this i didn't
have that
vocabulary i was just doing it and
nowadays you know participation has
become a key word
and every time when i have a new school
project
i'm changing the shape
because i hate it when people copy and
paste
dear student for detail please do me a
favor don't copy somewhere a detail and
put in your paper i will see it
immediately i don't like it you know so
for my people i wanted to give different
shape of the building so that that i
can't keep you know applying and
improving what i have brought and not to
keep replicating one what thing it that
is that is stagnation this is to me the
problem in in africa you have a school
model it's not even working well but i
keep replicating it
so
yeah many people start to ask for
project
and here one of the very first client
uh is a
surgeon
and he wanted to create a clinic he
applied to work with medicine frontier
a doctor without border and it didn't
take him because he didn't have enough
time to be there so he asked me if i can
help him create his clinic
so of course student i know how to draw
sketch
i just want to show you the images and
this is um this picture that i also have
thanks to ivan
what do you see is at the edge of the
city at the border of ghana but this
project is our tech it is
self-sufficient it produces electricity
water everything but if you see the kind
of solution that have been
taken inside this building out of math
you're gonna be surprised
and that is what i'm able to do you know
so later on so to think in my work now
if i start a project i see myself being
asked to add to add
so
actually i have like eight projects that
are not finishing because the client
keep asking to add because there is a
big request here you have doctor housing
but already i have to double the
capacity of the clinic that you see
yeah i'm using the material that is
available but i i like things that are
very
well done honestly this is
so
that is nutrition for me
and so
the clinic is
well done it's working well
um really people get fixed
um
kids are they're being happy while their
parents you know
getting fixed inside
who knows
who knows the continent very well you
know a clinic a hospital
is a place where no one goes
and
basically the simple problem is they
will go when it's too late
and so no one wants to go but if you go
it's place of dirt and no one like to go
there but if i see these kids playing in
a healthcare facility is so great to
myself
into i don't know how much time we have
but if you go down to that clinic you
will see hip hop from wagga dugou the
capital city of burkina faso going to to
do videos
and the first time when i saw that i
said wow hey what is here i want here
people to get fixed and you come to do a
song
and later i say wow it's good people are
looking for structures you know like to
be
like a frame for you know for their own
projection
and that is how my projects are and very
quick all i'm taking inspiration from
the traditional housing for the doctor
housing i'm giving them a size hoping
the passion will come or their family
and look at and and learn or let me use
the word copy in this case i say copy
the good product and bring it home so
i'm making little models that you could
put together to create a compare
so it's
collecting water
um it is
biomass it's so really good and inside
you have doctor staying and myself if i
go i'm staying there
if i'm
lucky to go with martin we may stay
there let hope
yeah and so no the work is basically
what you have seen and suddenly even in
the west people become aware about the
work and asking me to contribute to a
place is very quick here the serpentine
pavilion
this was the first project that has been
giving visibility uh so the kind that
people say oh he can do also in the west
so we did it sketches playing
um looking
the
fabric
of kensington garden the gallery
and then starting to do mocap and create
the structure that will fit
and
yeah it's almost like gandu i can't tell
you
uh you really design and think and then
people start to put things together
layering like brick by brick to create a
facade
um
intense look like an ufo
but
it's
done by people
so
this pavilion is now in kuala lumpur
first
2019 when i was here there was a plan
for me to go for a big inauguration it
has become a public library
but then kovid arrived postponing a lot
of things
but it's still
still happy to
yeah remember how fine it is it is wood
basically
it is three elements
wood
very thin metal structure
and
color
now
yes about creating gathering always if i
have a job i'm thinking how people will
come together this is important to me
it's about it and at the serpentine when
i was proposing i know i want people to
sit and land
and lean back and touch the facade i
think it was something new
but we did it
so
i also went to the u.s
that is a pavilion i was
had a chance to design for peter and
kathy
halstead uh
it is a couple
i don't know how to call them
philanthropists
artists themselves but really open and
very generous and the so the first word
when i met them they said you know
francis you helping build communities in
africa we want you to help us build our
community for a
fish day in montana i say wow
wow
so someone
a couple comparing my work with their
own work in the u.s and i was like wow
it gives you such a nutrition a
recognition you know that the work you
being see seeing as a a matter of heart
has that um
recognition and we did it
being inspired by the two goner
so
he's here is a little drama
this picture you see so nicely you
cannot see it anymore it is at the
border to mali
nowadays you cannot go in the past i
used to just take a car with ivan barr
will draw through
and just hang on and do things but you
cannot because it's unveiled by
terrorism so
i can go by myself alone
okay potentially not now anymore after
the media
thing that came to me but normally
i will go
but if you have an european looking
person with you
in the age of cell phone people will
call and say hey in this car is money
let's kidnap them
and you cannot go it's a tragedy
so however
getting inspired by those kind of
structure makes sketches horrendous also
student this is also part of what i'm
doing but looking to the beautiful
forest in montana and say wow this is
racials and then after i learned that
the native was using
this kind of wood to create the housing
i say wow let's use it and to create a
pavilion
and so
like very simple material
that we use it nina testing and that is
the pavilion
um
that is still standing
um
in uh in october i think that is
scheduled that i should go there to do a
movie it's called
uh
u.s by design they will be filming me in
that so many people will discover this
pavilion
i really like it because it's like part
of the landscape but being wood and
man-made
and in winter particularly it's melt
within
the
landscape
so
okay
but i have a lot of work to do in
burkina
so people asking and here i'll show you
very quick or a site i started to build
like a high school
that was the request that's a high
school and we did it now it has become a
campus
and called even i might uh bit
you know
maybe if i work i will call one day
something yeah because being inspired by
yeah for myself
but here was about mit
and then we we just designed this always
in my work i'm trying to increase
comfort inside the building
ventilation always and then to use like
a local material here this is later
right um that we just kept cutting it
give it up
you know for my people is a sense of
modernity but because it's regular you
know
they know this material they're being
using it it fit well to the climate wood
is a big issue in burkina faso there is
no wood
but we have an alternative this is
a calipers
it can be other spacious and i want to
just use this and then really create the
work something important
what i do there is a job
engine really a job engine so
when
you can understand that i have a
workshop that is bigger than 200
i have more than 200 people
um while i'm talking i mean they're
sleeping now of course
but normally i have like three four
construction sites going on somewhere in
burkina
and then they see the women
sending wood and they will earn money at
the beginning
when i succeeded in gando there was
adapt oh it was his village it was his
community so as a young
architect you have to prove you know
guys be ready so never give up if you
did it and you succeed somewhere they
will say oh no but don't give up sure
just keep going here we succeeded in
places that are 300 kilometers far from
ghana and creating a workshop that is
really working
and to yeah do a building like this
so after this building
we're asked to really design um i'm
rushing because i want to go to the
newest project that we have and you have
seen potential all of these images um so
some of these students are now visiting
oh already graduated in uh the next
project that i have created inside so
there is a big demand in this uh in
burkina faso but in the entire continent
it is keep growing and the fact is it
was
i showed the pictures before i cannot go
back i don't want the system to crash
but but when we started there was no
settlement really i was at the age and
now we're surrounded i wanted the client
i told him you know
if we build this and it is good and
successful and is working you know land
is going to be very expensive and that
is exactly what is happening
um
we cannot get more land to extend the
school
and so here because i'm traveling we
develop a modular system ventilation
system at class i can show more
but then
what we wanted to do is to really try
another way of building not to really
use bricks
but to pour
clay it's not ramen herb to pour it so
i'm trying to check the corner or the
cracking how can i improve it with my
team and then we go to production
here
the client was generous to help us with
the formwork
so with this you could pull one
classroom
and if you're good enough you could just
extend it and pull a sort of uh um
conference room
and that is what's happening now so it
means i can't just go
and then my people just
pour in classrooms and conference rooms
allowing the project to grow even
without me
so it's a lot of level
um
but you see how it is
so they will move it keep moving it and
it's just growing
um into the campus
it's really
yeah best
suited in burkina and
something that you may see there are
trees coming up
furniture
i keep doing them by sight on site
because the site becomes a production
place for me
and with the left over for the facade
we're creating benches that are
protecting at the same time trees
and it's always nice to see how it's
just shaping
very simple
this is clay
comfortable courtyard
wood as a ceiling i don't have money for
this here
you know
but i have alternative
so a tower
which is
even better but i had no time to
document or even for the preschool
family i was asked to go and be
photographed in every single of my
building but since i had no time to go
back but the tower looks so amazing and
kids has access to the world because it
is so high i changed it the client
wanted to put the metal
structure just one antenna said no
let's build a water tower underneath of
the water tower put administration for
the school and have a higher
you know structure to put the antenna
now student has connection to the world
you know
yeah and
hey honestly what i'm doing is bringing
light this work is like light in places
you know that has no opportunities
really
that is it
so
this is wrong it's not coming soon
because
um it is already reality i like this
project
it's a slack campus in turkana kenya
um i was asked to design a school so a
university and say okay wow good um but
this university is for people that has
no high school degree
so meant to recruit young refugees from
sudan ethiopia somalia but also
volunteer from kenya and then
give them a computer
and teach them digital designing and
they will be sitting somewhere far from
urban settlement and earn money
it was like a fiction
so you know but sometimes i like
fictions because i know who i am i came
from very poor background
and i was able to do that so that idea
looks like you will laugh about it
that's what i tried to did at the
beginning but up trusted him and look at
what we did first i discovered to kind
of so huge
and dry
okay
and people will gather
in front of the termite hill
i tried to learn from termite hail and
then design the building so you will see
the buildings later
i like this image
and that is what is happening inside
and these students are even trying to
design
they're not architects but they're
designing they're doing a lot of stuff
and then they're sitting really there
and being commissioned even from the us
and the first building was opened and in
during end of just end of covid and
kovidia number two it was already in
full function
and that is the building
and this is the laptop they got
what you need is energy and a building
that is
that is not consuming a lot of energy
and this is the result
so i got these pictures right now
because event is like tuning uh there
and you see
the the situation is really far from
yeah every urban structure
and what you see is the lake this lake
turkana is water but you cannot drink is
a not salty is it has a
yeah like salt water
and the landscape is so fragile
now it's about building housing for 300
kids
so
the project has been accepted and so
many students will stay there and so
we're designing working uh to build them
um
creating yeah corners
and then he tried to make light uh at
night
but the client also loved this light he
says you know uh francis we're bringing
hope
and again i bring you back to the notion
of light you know we're bringing light
to
places where there is no hope if you to
try to understand me you see that for
most young people an opportunity is to
go to the next big urban city
if you go to nairobi nairobi is so
crowded a lot of problems and then you
must
be really
good connected to have a great place
there but now they can stay in turkana
and access
education so
so the career started with little things
and then
with the time people really look at to
what i've been doing
and
so
here
an idea i should build a parliament
house
okay
so have
been asked to do many many things in my
career really
um
i always will really start start to
study and
check the sincerity
of the project and i will just enroll
here trying to imagine a gathering space
and also to learn from the nature but to
go back
in african trade west african tradition
where people just gather together under
a big tree and solve problems
it's real democracy if you sitting
in the shadow of a tree
you cannot sit uh like we're sitting you
know you're gonna sit
um around so everyone is
equals you know
and
uh while sitting because there is no
boundary
people will see you talking people will
come and sit
so it's really open you will be talking
taking a decision about the community
and your kids will standing and
listening to you or your your partner
you know and then you go you know that
you have to behave because that is
really transparent and i wanted to learn
from that and this is called uh albert
pallava tree if you
may translate and i wanted to learn from
that and just design a project
uh i design it um
and it's by now
my biggest project
um it is
now under construction
so it's
really
a big
um
now i can say
the idea of the pallava tree has been
choosing
but i think that the client didn't
really understood the complexity of the
project
and it made me suffer last year but i
don't talk about suffering i'm talking
about growing you know
because this is most of you here uh some
of the teachers been going over years
like working on big big project and so i
saw myself facing these but in this
project i was not just the architect can
you imagine i was in charge of
everything in french it's called mission
complete
and i told i put it like a big character
to my office if ever something like this
enter this office you have to say no
really no yeah mission complex means you
have to be in charge of everything
understand everything
now everything talking to you now
i just happened to change the contract
and now the government is taking all
these other you know
staff and i'm now in charge of the
architecture
oh
i can tell you
yeah
it's construction as i told you i
couldn't put the images that is it it's
like a giant like we the dream was to
create the bigger tree inside a
botanical garden and it's coming short i
think in less than two years we're gonna
be so far
the funny thing
when we went to start construction there
was a meeting and i was called hey mr
architect we want to add a cup a mill a
casser like for soldier
for 200 soldiers inside the site
room for 200 soldier
the project was finished
you have to go again and work and work
and work oh my gosh
yeah okay funny thing let's go but i'm
still dealing on scale projects like
this one for dr awuma
in kenya kogelu
i have become serious but
in normal time i will tell you if you
look at today's
you know people in kogelu
say people will come
to kenya to check the house of the obama
but because this is a village but now
people come to check a house that is
flying
and for me it's like an honor you
understand you know
so it's showing what the power of our
profession you know
um
this project is so far good because i
collaborated with people i couldn't be
on site it's like what's up it's about
correspondence and talking back and
forward but we we made it and again i
got these pictures from ivan is always
about hey honestly to make people happy
really to create an environment that is
positive for teaching for celebrating
and doing whatever
yeah so here we just arranged the volume
the way that it's just curved while you
have a big gathering it is open but then
you have like a sort of semi public
private where people can gather in
little groups it's really really small
and rich yeah
and i from outside also you have like a
way where you could just uh gather and
from outside people will be watching and
checking what is inside um
and so
here
the project that i will show you before
ending
i couldn't find a picture before
because it was time was short
but what you see is a playground in
kampala
uganda um
it's in an informal settlement there was
no space
there was just this space that people
showed to us with a lot of conflicts
because of encroachment
um and um i've been working for
five years
in this project back and forward
really trying to negotiate space some of
the people took
the space of
the public space which belonged to a
church
kcc
and many other organization and we had
to really negotiate with the neighbor
people will be playing ball they will be
playing shark whatever a lot of games
unboxing and bodybuilding studio in this
little little space
and the problem by playing ball is the
ball flare in the neighboring plot
the neighbor is good take the ball and
through again and he's happy
another neighbor the ball will fail he
take a knife cut it
so a lot of conflicts a lot of conflict
and then
we being dealing going back and forward
back and forward and to do it and that
is how you see it how it's full packed
yeah and i really
thanks even for these pictures
we happen to really create a multi-uh
functional structure
so here we wanted to create
many many form of gathering even little
cozy place for people to be happy look
at these faces can you see you know
also these faces
and and this is all about this project
um
even was scheduled to stay one day he
ended up staying three four days because
i know his schedule is so full packed
but this little
place is so
used that you cannot imagine
myself i haven't had the chance to go
um
but it's like um
um you know this is what you hope you
created and
people take ownership
uh using every corner
really
you see the existing and the new one
even in term of colors we was able to
adapt but
you you
i was told by my people that the floor
was so flat the kids has a new game
they call it sliding they just run and
shoot in the in the floor and
it was it's incredible you know it's
incredible
yeah and so
we brought a water tower
because
water can be so cell that can be sold
there
or used to wash butter butter
um
and at night
you have many
kind of place
normally at night it's dangerous you
don't go there
and yeah it is it it has become the most
visited site in kampala
can you imagine
in an informal settlement and now is a
little conflict we have like a storage
and they say no we should make it out of
it people are sometimes exaggerating we
make uh exclusive coffee there are
people that are wealthy should come and
and so then the question what to do with
the butter butter so but that is so
amazing so someone asked today what is
the community part of project if you
work in this area it is you have to deal
a negotiate you know
so
and you could see
roads
have light during night but
so you have like little little
light
inside the components but now you have
the light for the community
and
i love water towers
i love to build them i've been traveling
across africa documenting water towers
and i don't know if i can use the word
hate
but they're so
nightmare
so ugly so
and i have decided to do water towers
differently
and this is like
the thing you did it
we draw it's like reverse really i i
tested many times in booking and we just
sent the drawing and jonathan was able
to really make it happen
he
coordinated everything
yeah
in the heart of informal settlement
playing watching
being part of it
so
thank you very much
[Applause]
you
thank
be happy to you a few questions before
we go back over to the school of
architecture
let me ask that if you have a question
you stand
and you can take your mask off are there
microphones yes
back there okay thank you if you have a
question please walk to the back cross
aisle stand in front of the microphone
take your mask off when we ask you a
question so everybody can hear you
uh and we'll do it
just
hey
awesome
um
so i was just
my question is about the form of your
buildings how do you think about the
shape of the building so that it's it's
regular it's it's detailed but it's not
oppressive and people are still feel
like it's friendly
it's
okay it's
first about i mean i don't think about
the shape but i'm thinking about how i
can protect first the building itself
with the roof
uh you know so
against uh sun
you know but also to create a shadow
and the rest is like a putting things
together and get it done and so and i
i really like things that are accurately
done
and
and you know and inspiring to people so
the place where i grew
was honestly speaking not a place
that can inspire young people and that
is the primary reason why i started to
do architecture and so in everything
where i'm what i'm i'm doing is just to
make sure that everything fit
thinking about the economy but to
protect but to provide space where you
could just even use outside the building
you know this is
simply the thing that i'm doing
cool thanks
um thank you for your presentation
are you studying here
okay good
you will do better roofs
um
i think my question has to do with the
materials like in the variety of the
project that you have showed us
um
there is a certain focus on using local
materials perhaps because of the
because of the the brief or the
standards or the context or the
availability of these materials in there
but i i just wanted to ask
like if there was ever any room
to go into these local contexts and use
different materials entirely and how
receptive
what would the people be and i'm asking
this because there's always
um there's often this fear of
marginalization of like marginalizing
people with certain materials of context
so what would happen
if we bring in like a different material
and what is the possibility of doing
that
so
what kind of different material
something that is
not present in the context for example
in africa something that is not clay
may be concrete maybe any other material
that would seem fit for the project yeah
so um basically
i mean one day i just said i am a
material opportunist
yeah
not a materialist no
like good stuff but i want to say
no i want to say if i go to a place i'm
looking
it's it's very simply and it's
it's for me
the the easier thing to do look at what
is the most available how can i use
these in a smart way i don't say that
i'm smart but i hope i am but i'm
talking to apply the you know the rules
of architecture and come out with
something that's really work it's about
design it's about structure it's about
security but also
so comfort and those things are guiding
me and i will use everything even uh
cement block if i
have nothing else than that i will use
if i
i will even say i will use sand then but
i needed another structure to to support
the the sun you know sandbags for
example but i think
there is no limit it is up to you really
to try and then um i'm looking if
something is there i'm doing also sort
of research i will try to see
how can i use this material in the
different way but to achieve quality i
will try and then
for many people in many places with
building
it's about
having a precedence to create something
that i see say oh wow
this work
but if it's
like really well done
and inspiring
then there is no limit
i i have no taboo regarding material
i use also concrete i mean it needs
basement sometimes yeah
yeah but she she did like that
she was happy
hi um thank you so much for the
presentation but um so my question is
actually quite broad
i'm just wondering since because um
africa is
at this moment like the um youngest has
the youngest population and the fastest
growing population as well so which
means at like now there are a lot of
kids there but in like 20 30 years
they're kind of growing to working at
all and then like 50 something years
they'll become like elders so i'm
wondering
um do you have any thoughts on how can
architecture respond to
this like changing demand from like a
lot of educational buildings to like
working buildings to maybe like
buildings for the elders um in africa
especially on kind of the budget control
and the material use
well it's really broad yeah sorry about
that yeah no i mean it's um
this is
let's say we have a survey now
we know that it's a big need but we also
know population is growing and then it's
us to adapt you know and then the more
people you educate
and then the more example you're showing
and then you know make it accessible uh
people will keep transforming it so in
my case i mean if i say those that are
connected to uh information knows what
it is
i mean ever in burkina faso have the
feeling that every second person want to
become architect you know they know this
word again um everyone wants to do that
i think that
you know you will have a lot of young
people being interested and then being
trained and when they become 30 or
professional they will just care and so
learning from what exists to really keep
growing and and care or create structure
that sweet every um every need even for
elderly um
what i if i'm thinking about the school
and whatever that is easy but then um
there is a structure regarding the
family so
um
the compound idea in cities you will be
alone but if you come to the countryside
people are really living in a family
we would have to develop ideas that
sweet very well you know
you use
my attempt by the project and level
uh create a sort of house that you can
just
apply you know you could transform it
and so this will allow those kind of
structure to really
be adapt to the number of people but
also um
be sprayed you know i think that is it
i'm
i'm not quite sure if i answer to your
question but i think it's it's that is a
question of evolution and it will it
will work yeah it will work people are
aware now you know they have a prisca
winner
yeah and they can win the prescott no i
mean
it is important
it's very important
yeah so i have become a very serious
person i have to be careful
okay you say it like this okay good
thank you for the visual feast this is
incredible um i i also had a question
about
kind of materials and methods because
you're working in so many different
locales i would imagine there's
a lot of different um
kind of
bases of construction knowledge that
differ from each other and what i've
noticed from
these images is that there's
if not consistency a lot of attention
paid to detail to things
all the way from sight grading when you
have walkways made out of the pavers to
the the thickness of the mortar that's
laid between the brick when you're
working in all these different locales
do you draw a lot more do you talk a lot
more what is it that you try to do to
get the
the methods to work for you in so many
different places
i think this is key
um also you will see that my world is
transformative um
it also the locate depend on the
location if you work in a really
countryside where there is no
um nothing else in the middle of nature
you limited you know
the the auction to the building and then
you could plant trees
so to come come if you work in the urban
area so you know you have to deal with a
lot of issues that will push you to
really
find ways paving uh the commercial
project is kamvokia is um what you got a
wet a wet area is like a
subject of flooding all the time and
then it took us a very long time because
we had a main channel getting all of the
water out at this middle
in in our plot so if you start with all
of these you start with ideas to
make things fix and so protect the
entire if like you let one corner
untreated and then it will be a weakness
that may destroy all these stuff but
depending where i am
or pavement can be made with really
rough material like granite i do it a
lot in gando i couldn't i didn't want to
show a lot of things but because
for the moment i'm trying to reduce uh
the visibility not to show show
building a huge high school and then if
you see how it's working uh we're using
rocks um to really create the landscape
and plant trees because it's very dry
no i'm adapting
where i am if i'm working in germany is
a different area i'd even wanted to show
all of these and to get those that loves
me be afraid
that i'm working too much but i'm i'm
happy really to do it i'm checking uh
it's also about availability uh you know
resources if you don't have a lot of
resource you limit it you you be you
know you will limit the you know the
extension of the project landscaping
can be
rough you know and not very
defined like in the city
yeah
okay he made like
that hello francis
my name is ryan uh me and my friends we
drove three hours to come hear you and
it was well worth it
um my question is pretty specific but i
was also really intrigued by the water
tower
and i saw how like the water gathers at
the top but like kind of the bracing
mechanic the wiring frame
between like the top and bottom i
couldn't really understand
how the water would transfer down or
like how the people would
receive like i didn't see no kind of
pipe system or maybe yes there's a pipe
there's a pipe actually
what we found on site we found
that someone was selling water to the
border border driver to clean their
border border so actually what i do if i
come to a place and i have a job like
this i will really try to study and try
to fit to everything and so the idea
with the water tower camp you have seen
a sort of concrete base you know it is
like where you have a tap you could get
the water and someone is selling it's a
and then we have solar that is pumping
the water
we we just secure everything and we're
collecting on the
and the pavement i was asked about we're
collecting all the water on the site uh
you know because water is contaminated
and we're storing all the water and we
will depending on the use you will pump
it and then you go oh okay it's a pipe
okay and solar is it it's not expensive
yeah
very interesting thank you
you're welcome
so let plan one you know let's design
one
hello uh so i've got
just one question i think first of all
it's amazing to have you here and it's
amazing to hear about all the work
you're doing for your people in africa
but you know i think a challenge with a
lot of architecture in developing
nations is that
the long-term upkeep and maintenance of
it
and
i'm just wondering long-term long-term
maintenance and upkeep yes so i'm just
wondering how do you consider that
challenging your design like do you try
to make something that is easy to
maintain or do you try to make something
that's
you know maybe easy to fix up with
what's available yeah
or this is key
maintenance is a big big problem
and then so if you see the project that
why so the detailing is also so
high
because i want to make them first stable
and durable
and then to reduce the amount of
maintenance
and also to give ideas like the
parliament house i'm going to the big
one
we was lucky that the government is
working with us decided to increase the
budget i think even five percent of the
badges was kept somewhere for the to
maintain the big building
but in reality maintenance has always
been a big big issue public building are
not maintained is a big problem if you
start to build this place
um it's up to you to come with solutions
that are not subject easily subject to
you know to to be destroyed and you have
to fix them um you you're right but that
is part of the way i'm working and i'm
checking how can i really fix them and
if it's in uh in burkina faso i have
like a big team that is able to maintain
and to fix things and so
next to being an architect i have
developed a structure
that is
caring for building i cannot say you
what we're doing but we're doing
everything fixing electric installations
water supply
deep wells and so we're doing this but
everyone here if you want to build you
have to make sure
the building is stable and come out with
less maintenance because few people will
care for it so especially if it's
governed in buildings
okay are you okay
thank you you're welcome
you francis for your lecture um i want
to ask you if
you think there's a major lesson from
the way
you create something
relatively simple but so powerful in
areas that doesn't have much else into
societies that are relatively abundant
the key look
creating something huh
[Music]
yeah
yeah i think i'm yeah i'm facing this
question but because we're in the family
uh we try to i'm
i don't know um i don't know i'm
seeing myself i am now someone living in
abundance i have a lot of great people
uh great mammals
um
you know and
you know it's
one of the privilege so but i think if
i'm thinking back to
places where people just deal with this
the the minimum um what we
is there's two two answers
so we may say i don't care don't give a
[ __ ] but i will not do that because we
say it's normal so i don't want them to
learn from those people but i i think we
all can be a little bit more modest you
know um
we all can save a little bit more and
then we can learn
to from how people live in scarcity we
don't need to
to be like an escape as a sketch as
ask it ascetic
huh yeah we don't need to be that we
don't need to refuse a lot but i think
we could learn a little bit to really
start to save um
your question is so fundamental
because we're seeing every government in
the west and then in the rest of the
other world everyone is struggling
because of her covet
you know we saw that we really need
goods that we cannot have and maybe we
start to reduce consumption
to know that resources are limited and
so i i think
that is a message that we can really
look at you know i think that we cannot
just keep consuming like we do
i don't want people to start to be poor
like people in burkina faso but
you know we need to think about energy
and to see how other people from in
other culture are behaving you know
can learn a little bit
are you satisfied yes yeah okay you have
to
thank you thank
you thank you
i'm done
i made it
i made it i